so it's been some comments on some other
computerphile videos asking what an
Arduino is so we're going to cover what
makes different arduino z' and how you
can get involved in them why they're so
good show some little examples and talk
about some other alternatives to the
mainstream arduino so here I have a dual
Malev forum 2009 this is my first
Audrina and that you came in a kit so it
gives you a kit of all the components of
things so basically what an Arduino is
is a open-source electronics platform so
it allows people who aren't necessarily
very knowledgeable electronics like
myself to really easily get involved to
make cool things so as a quick example
of that here we have a breadboard
basically a solderless circuit so allows
you to just plug things into these slots
we're about to solder anything so it's
really easy and clean to get involved
with latronnik so the audrina has a set
pin so we've got our of analog and power
pins and a row of digital pins we've got
a couple of wires here just to plug into
your dueño and then this is a piece of
elements it's for play sound and that's
pretty much it on the digital pins the
Arduino our output digital signals to
control electronics and on the power and
the analog pins output analog signals
for output our obviously we're going to
plug the red cable into the five volt
and the black cable into the ground so
these just provide the power so they're
just completing the electrical circuit
here you've got the power pins and some
analog pins and over here you've got
your digital pins just blue one is our
data pin and this goes in the digital
slot nine it's not as neat yet so it
goes in nine okay so that's now
everything plugged in so we've got the
speaker is taking data from pin 9 and
yard we know because the program we've
written just happens to send data report
now so then looking at the board we have
this red rail which is our five volt
rail and the blue one which is our
ground rail so that's where the power is
coming from we then have this blue cable
coming from speaker into the data and we
have the ground cable going to the
speaker to complete the circuit here we
have the Arduino IDE
so Audrey know is programmed with a
variation on see a basic Arduino program
has a set up and a loop and then there's
a lot of different functions available
to access the things on the board for
example here you've got digital right so
that writes something to a digital pin
forward tents and purposes it is C we're
going to plug the IDE in
to the Audrina so on this one it's a
rather crusty and old USB B but newer
ones use micro USB
it's my code so this will set up the
speaker the plate so I'm going to
compile it first make sure there's no
Emma's so Arduino programs are typically
called sketches it kind of gets across
the idea that Arduino is made for
hobbyists and artists not so much
programmers so that's now compiled at
you can see from here so it's done
compiling and we've got nice little
output that tells us what is compiled
and how many bytes for used etc okay now
I'm going to upload it so now push it to
the Arduino so it's compiling the sketch
again so you can see some lights are
flashing on here now as it uploads you
choose not all I'm very unmusical II
sound so on this file we've got a red
beats and we've got an array of notes
with each note we have a tone and the
tone is output to the digital pin and
then sense the speaker you can see here
pinmode speaker pin output so the pin
that that's poked into is in output mode
and we've named a speak of him and in
the loop we just play back the list up
there so we're delaying it by the beats
set the tempo and then we're playing
notes if we're not currently playing a
note then we delay if we are playing a
note then we play the note that we're
currently on Arduino has come quite a
ways to start in 2005 when it first
started they didn't realize how big the
uptake would be in terms of people
customizing accessories so this pin
layout has kind of become a fixed form
factor so we look at this once this is
the new Arduino unit from 2013 odd so
it's got the exact same pin layout and
it's more or less the exact same size so
people have made things called shields
which are basically accessories that
provide other functionality and they
plug into the pins on top so you have
odd we know compatible boards which are
similar boards or similar functionality
that works to this pin layout the whole
part forms open-source as many clones
that use the same pin layout there's
many accessories and shields that use
the same pin layout so it's con they've
kind of inadvertently made the next hold
where standard there's multiple forms of
Arduino compatible so I mean if you look
at these two so these are completely
compatible so they've got the same
layout so they're compatible with
Arduino shields so she would have to
cross bronze this layout but then you
can have things that Arduino compatible
in that they use the same software and
use same development environments this
is DIY arduino called a shrimping it
it's made of a shrimp kit this does
roughly have the same pin layout but
it's not in the same shape so you
couldn't plug a shield into this event
modification but this does this can be
programmed by the arduino ide and uses
the arduino software so this is still
arduino compatible this is actually
based on one of the more popular arduino
at moment the unit and does all the same
stuff it's just much much cheaper so i
mean one of these i one of these we have
all the components the stuff cost about
60 pound one of these with all the
components these are costing us about 20
pounder kit 60 pounds which is probably
what $100 something like that no but
people ripping them off they're kind of
there was a big there is a big issue
with so these ones they don't mind they
encourage this sort of thing where
someone makes a clone a cheaper clone
and makes it open-source and provides
the parts exception don't like that the
big problem they have is chinese
companies making arduino clones calling
them arduino and then selling them for
nine dollars that's the big issue they
currently have because they don't have
the mark of quality these ones do mean
if you look at their duma loath if
they're very fond of their circuit board
arts you get a nice little picture of
italy there and this whole blue PCB
thing was kind of trend kind of started
by them rather than putting the green
circuit board covering on they left it
blue and they've kind of started to
transfer to PCBs the only Arduino boards
that allowed to be called Audrey nose
are those made by the Arduino foundation
cells but surely the source controller
it's not people ripping off and cloning
it they're conservative it's the Arduino
name so it's more of a trademark issue
then a technical issue or an integer
property issue they just don't like
people they want people if you buy a
board with Arduino written on if you buy
board from Arduino you they want you to
know that it's quality and it's made in
Italy and it's got this whole homebrew
feel about it whereas you don't want to
be buying a cheap knockoff for nine
dollars that's going to break in about a
month like how one frequently does and
have that called Nidorino so to more
extreme degree you have the makey makey
so we use one of these in the
texting with a recorder video basically
what these are are they a really easy
way for kids to get on electronics allow
you to plug things in and make
controllers so they work on an electric
potential so floppy you can plug fruit
in and touch the fruit and it'll trigger
a key press
so they using the same microprocessor
the Audrina's are the pin layouts
completely different and they don't
really act like an Arduino does but they
are based on the Arduino software and
you can unlock the full Arduino minute
and get more at get more control of it
so these are not necessary or Drina
compatible but based upon Arduino so
this is the rostra pipe so this is
covered in the earlier video and this is
kind of taken the hobby electronic world
by storm and as a result a lot P of
heard of Raspberry Pi but not
necessarily Arduino you've know Audrina
spent a lot longer so the key
differences between this is this is a
full computer this one the next as
opposed to the small microcontroller of
an Arduino and while this does have pins
that you can use for digital input and
output and various other standards and
like I squared C in that sort of thing
it doesn't have the full range of
digital and analog capabilities that the
Arduino does so it's not as good for
hobbyist hardware and because it is a
full blown computer and has a full
operating system it's not as easy to
mess around with stuff so if you wanted
to flashing LED over all through pi
you'd have to install an operating
system on it enable the output pins
write a program for it whereas with an
Arduino plug it in upload a program plug
an LED into a slot you're good to go so
I'll do a nose rose requires use quite a
lot in Internet of Things hacks like
sensors around your house or common
everyday items and combine them together
to do different functions
so the Arduino is really good cos it's
really well powerful senses but it
doesn't really have any internet
connectivity so how we've done this
previously is we attached the Arduino to
a Raspberry Pi and then we differ rows
by wireless adapter and then we collect
data from the internet with Rosser PI I
feed it to Audrina which was a lot of
components and it had a lot of points of
failure but with the new odd Reno's so
the odd we know you and being one of
them this is kind of a hybrid between
the PI and the Arduino Uno
or the Dhumal over this case so what you
have here is a Linux system on a chip
and the a-team mega microcontroller so
you've got an Arduino chip and a Linux
system on one chip and it's also has
Wi-Fi so this is a really neat cell you
don't need to worry about having two
boards and you don't have to worry about
Wi-Fi adapters I mean the Wi-Fi
configuration on the rascal is a
complete pain it's been the death of
more than one hack whereas with this
plug it in it makes a Wi-Fi network you
connect to the Wi-Fi network then goes
to a nice configuration page you tell it
which network to connect to and that's
just done it's on the internet you've
got full Linux computer running the
internet which also has an Arduino on it
and you can program this over Wi-Fi so
you don't use any cables so it's really
good for hobbyists and people doing
stuff at home but it's also has very
serious uses and usages so for example
there's a project called DRG Satna which
is making tiny satellites out of Arduino
and their CubeSat
so basically they're to a certain
standard so the tiny little cube
satellites and they are fully run by
Arduino so people are launching these
into space to do very serious
applications so it's gone from being a
fun little hobbyist platform for
interactive artists and people making
remote-control cars and solar panels and
button games to actually being used in
hobbyist space programs the standards
fermentation kits come with a light
sensor and a motor so it's really easy
to rig up things for example like a
solar panel that tracks are some you've
got lights inside you can program it to
keep track of the light and follow the
light and then the motor would just turn
whatever assembly you've got to hold
your solar panel